oui à la diction nous nous la rendons un
peu moins austère aussi
nous nous prenons des textes extraits de
l'hebdomadaire pour jeunes maintenant et
un rédacteur d'un hebdomadaire pour
jeunes s'est attaché à faire des textes
de diction pour rire et qui malgré tout
sont très efficaces écoutez voir le
texte et de alessandrini notre ami jean
pierre darroussin va vous le dire
on se tourne
il était une fois dans le monde des
chats deux royaumes dont les monarques
s'entendait comme chiens et chats
c'était le royaume de lebara cha et
celui de chipolatas marbach a été le
pacha de lebara de chasse était un
patriarche nu mais chaleureux qui allait
chaque jour sans chichis faire ses
achats au marché des bars à chicha
moustache a était un pouce à havas chier
chauvin menait une vie de patachon et
chouchouté rachid maréchal très méchant
occupé les fonctions de chat à neuf
queues quant à rachid il l'est chez les
chaussures de moustache a et ce
cachottier chafouin louchet sur la
charge de son chef hiérarchique
lemarchal rachiki par des approches
choisi pousser son chèque à une guerre
contre le pacha dans le but de
s'approprier les deux royaumes vite
enfin sa chance lui échoir en effet
sachez que catéchisés palais rabâchage
du chemin neuf que kesha faudel des
chimères anarchique moustache a déchiré
la charte des chats et déclencha le
chambardement contre barbacha le placide
pacha se fâcha de cette vacherie et
dépêcha sans flancher ces chevaliers
contre les chars du chèque la guerre
était donc commencer les champs de
bataille c'est schaller dans la chaîne
des chapeliers
embuscade échauffourées s'y succédèrent
les archers lâcher des flèches qui se
fichait l'internation des chevaliers
chargeant avec panache juchés sur leurs
chameaux et ceci dans une surenchère des
chalets s'accroche à coups de perche et
se trancher l'accrocher à coups de hache
approcher ceux qui étaient touchés je
suis tellement les charbons sous le choc
et on achevait sans charité est amochée
ce fut un beau gâchis de chat et le
charnier qui résulte à cette boucherie
aurait pu s'éterniser si le maréchal
rachid n'était tombé dans une embuscade
est mise en échec par l'archiduc
charabia le fils de farrah chatte
transféré et devant le pacha de débarras
cha il avoua que le challenge au style
du tchèque n'était due qu'à ses
chantages comprenant la chose barbacha
composer un concordat moustache a que
celui ci accepte sans rechigner les deux
monarques se rencontrèrent donc au
château de chatière ce fut la
réconciliation et ils décidèrent de
châtier rachid ce chenapan déchu que la
chance avait lâché il se chargeait de
chaîne et jeté dans un cachot sous un
temps où elle fut fêtée 40 pons a
exceptionnellement qui avait de quoi
fouetter un chat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]